coming up on 5 25 on your wednesday  morning okay so we may not like the  orange cones the road construction  projects that slow us down but we should  not ignore or disrespect the men and  women who put on the hard hats on those  brightly colored vests to get the work  done it's part of national work zone  awareness week the folks at the utah  department of transportation found a  neat way to drive home the point that  every person on every work crew has a  family  he comes to all my baseball games  he makes me laugh with this funny jokes  he's the leader of my scout group  she gives me hugs and kisses and keeps  me safe  because the things he does helps all of  us  our parents are at work  [Music]  man if that doesn't get you and i'm  pretty sure that director christina  swallowed everybody at the nevada  department of transportation would say  here here to that buckle up drive  carefully and please put on that phone  some driving to crazy email me traffic 8  8newsnow.com